john mcclane is going to call in right
now we're thrilled to have him from the
houston chronicle
because nothing's happening in houston
john so we thought we'd just
you know call you you know chat and
catch up see what you had for breakfast
i'll be happy to talk about the only
dual threat quarterback in the nfl
is throwing passes and lining up at
safety
[Laughter]
what in tarnation is happening in
houston john i feel like you're the only
guy that can really break it down for us
well desean watts will never play
another snap for the texans he wants to
be traded they want to trade him they've
been trying to trade him
since march but because of the 22 civil
suits
accusing him of sexual assault and
misconduct 10 complaints
with the houston police department and
investigation
and an investigation by the nfl it could
turn out to be a full season suspension
half a suspension
or no suspension all that uncertainty
not to mention watson's no
trade clause nobody's showing any
interest right now
and at some point maybe they will so
watson reported to avoid
the fifty thousand dollar day fines so
they have him as the fourth quarterback
on the practice field because they know
he's not going to play for them and as
part of his role
his the throat passes during the
warm-ups to his receivers and then
stand off to the sideline or behind the
huddle
and then when they want to give some
looks to some quarterbacks
they have guys going to stand in the
secondary in like two deep coverage so
he stands there
twiddles his thumbs he's had his cell
phone he could check his
text and instagram but uh it seems like
a waste to me
should be in the facility working out on
his own
as if he were injured but he's on the
field it's a side show yesterday
was the biggest circus-like atmosphere
i've ever
seen since the oilers left town for
nashville
and then today most of the circus left
town and there were still
a few of us around chronicling his every
move
john mclean here from the houston
chronicle joining us here on the rich
eisen show
john how is this going to affect the
team and the chemistry of the team when
they see him going through the motions
like this
well first of all david culley is a new
coach nick cereal new gm so it's not a
distraction and it's not
on the field i've watched every pass
it's not like
he's interfering davis mills the rook he
talked to him a little bit today
and some of the coaches talked to him
and a few of the players from last year
have talked to him
with 50 new players including 42
veterans
a lot of them don't know him unless it's
from the pro bowl or when they played
against him or with him
in college so it's a very awkward
situation a very strange situation
nothing like i've ever seen and they'll
just make the best of it david culley
the coach said we asked him is this what
we're going to see
every day he said we're on day that and
nick casario told us it's a day-to-day
endeavor
without saying it that means it could
change at any any point
somebody steps up makes them a good
offer he's gone
who could make the offer though right
now john because why would anybody make
an offer
on a quarterback in which you don't know
what the
outcome will be we don't know whether
the commissioner could get involved
whether this could go criminal there are
so many civil
suits i mean how would somebody and why
would somebody
make that overture with such an
open-ended ending susie the only thing i
think of is if there's a team and they
say okay
we'll make this deal we will absorb the
criticism that comes
with trading for a player with all these
legal issues
over his head but at some point whether
it's
not it's 21 or 22 it'll be behind it
and when it is he's a great quarterback
he played great last year
watson was outstanding it didn't
translate into victories it wasn't his
fault the defense was awful
30th overall 32nd against the run they
couldn't run the ball
31st in rushing but he was tremendous
and i'm guessing a team would do it with
the idea
we might just write off 2021
and if we get him this year that's great
and we're looking more for 2022.
if you were to make an offer now when
nothing is resolved
i'm guessing it would be a lot cheaper
than if it went to say
before next year's draft and he had
everything behind him and a bunch of
teams
interested in acquiring him i mean you
make an incredibly great point selling
point there
i just go back to the circumstances
of 22 to 23. you know i i don't know
anybody who has 22 to 23 different
people i mean i've covered sports for 20
something years
and usually athletes have one or two
people that is it that they'll let touch
them and it's just
it's there are so many questions here
john
that i just can't imagine being the team
that would take the chance even if it
was financially
palatable susie
it's 22 is unprecedented of course
there's never been any situation like
this
in nfl history and but
desean is a great player he's 20 26
years old
he's under contract through 2025
very popular with his teammates but if
you read those
civil seats and i've read every word
of all of them there are disturbing
accusations in there those accusers
deserve to be heard just like he's
innocent until proven guilty and so
far we don't think they're any closer to
a resolution now than they were
three months ago this story's not going
anywhere john
no it sure isn't while he's getting all
the attention and while that's been the
focus you wrote about running backs and
receivers who aren't getting the
the attention down there what are you
seeing well nobody's getting attention
here
but watson it's almost like oh there are
other players out here
before training camp and before watson
reported to save the
50 000 a day fines everything was about
davis mills to rod taylor is the starter
david mills is davis mills their first
draft choice in third round
and at some point this season they've
got to see him extensively because
if he makes them believe he can be the
quarterback it changes
next year's draft if he doesn't they got
to get a quarterback with the first pick
could be first overall they're going to
run the ball a whole lot more to take
the pressure off
the defense take the pressure off to rod
taylor they've
they've got four veterans three are new
and that's david culley's
philosophy that's nick casario's
philosophy
john mclean from the houston chronicle
we appreciate your time and chris you
got a question
yeah john nba draft tonight what's
houston going to do at number two
well i think they would love to have
kate cunningham we've watched him at
oklahoma state last year and he's good
in everything he's not like right away
superstar can't miss like say zion was
but he can do everything i'm sure that
the rockets would look
to pull somebody else but i think our
longtime nba rockets writer jonathan
fagan has had jalen green
in all of his mocks and if he says it
it's good enough for me
yeah joe and green's kind of an
interesting guy played in the g league
last year
uh and kind of rising up up draft boards
uh where does he fit in with you guys
if he does go to houston at number two
well first of all they have two more
number ones they haven't had a number
one pick here since 2015.
so we don't know how to act we don't
know if you're supposed to tune into the
first round
well daryl was making too many moves
that's exactly right and now you got to
be watching after top
that's like i say about the texans
you're going to be bad be all the way
back get the top pick
now the rockers were the worst team they
ended up with a second pick
i think they look at him as a shooting
guard who could penetrate
he could shoot anywhere on the floor
they considered
mobley but they man they got christian
wood and they thought about jalen suggs
but
i think they like green they'd love to
have cunningham i think any team would
he'll be an instant starter unless
they've made a huge mistake
okay you mention all the draft picks you
guys got a lot of people a lot of
experts are expecting a lot of trades
tonight
is houston gonna package some of these
and and get a veteran or
do you see anything like that on the
table there's been a lot of speculation
about trading eric gordon and those two
picks in the 20s
to the pacers and getting the pacers
other pick in the first round
and then i don't know what they would do
with it but you know three rookies are
not going to make what's a young team
already
so i'm all for trading those picks for a
higher one
and then taking your chances and have
two rookies instead of three
john you were speaking rich's language
by the way when i talked about
bombing if you're gonna bomb just bomb
out that's how he feels about the jets
but look what happened again
well rich ought to be used to it because
it happens to the jets all the time and
so far they haven't been able to do it
and maybe zach wilson will be the second
best quarterback
in franchise history it's too bad that
the jets
uh couldn't have traded that second
overall pick to the
texans to take deshaun watson because he
would have been
the second best quarterback in franchise
history john you've covered this league
for a long time speaking of the nfl
what are your top story lines as we get
ready for another season
uh the covet 19 and the variance and the
any income poops that won't get
vaccinated it just blows me away
i just don't understand it we're sitting
here at the houston medical center
with the top medical people in the
country telling us to do it
it took me nine seconds to get two
vaccinations
and i thank god when i was in the first
grade polio
was causing a big problem around the
country they made us
get vaccinations and we didn't complain
our parents
didn't complain and basically wiped it
out but i think
it's going to have a profound effect on
the nfl this season considering
if you cause a problem and you forfeit
and if you miss the playoffs
by one game or home field advantage
because you were too
ignorant or stupid or both to get the
vaccination you've let down your
self your team your fans and your
organization and i think it's just
adorable yeah the week came out today
with some numbers looks like 88 percent
of the players have at least had
one shot there's a few teams over 95
percent where is houston
uh on that list where are they in terms
of team vaccinations they were at 80
a couple weeks ago we asked nick casario
yesterday
he wouldn't say where they are he said
they made improvement they're happy with
it
and praised his players but he wouldn't
tell us anything but he
never tells us anything he wouldn't tell
us deshaun watson was about to walk on
the field
when we all start with our own eyes when
he talked to us before practice
michael irvin actually said it very well
this week he said if you really want to
win get vaccinated and he actually
challenged people i like that the
playmaker that's maybe the
smartest thing he's ever said well he
said it
and he followed up with it on nfl.com
anybody can check that out as well but
john thank you for your time we so
appreciate it stay safe down there and
throw that mask on
susie thank you very much and please
give rich my best thank you
i sure will thanks john john mclean from
the houston chronicle great having him
on hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here